[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan Marco land in
Dublin kicking off their first overseas
tour as a married couple
it's their first official trip to the
Republic of Ireland they're going to be
doing a handful of engagements there's
gonna be quite a whistle-stop tour Megan
stunned in a forest screen is Yvonne she
top and pencil skirt paired with 10
heels and a tan purse as she stroked the
tarmac at Dublin Airport alongside her
handsome hubby on Tuesday it's an
important tool so we're going to see how
they are as a married couple as a team
how they're received and yeah sets the
tone for the future and here's why royal
watcher Katie Nichol says the trip is so
significant I think the fact that Harry
and Megan have been asked by the Foreign
Office to go to Ireland shows just how
much faith the Queen has in both of them
as working Royals you know the Queen
would have approved that trip she would
have made sure she was happy with the
itineraries earlier in the day the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex took Britain by
storm alongside Prince William and Kate
Middleton the Fab Four as they've been
dubbed looked regal as they attended a
service celebrating the 100th
anniversary of the royal air force at
Westminster Abbey
[Applause]
and they were all smiles while watching
a military fly past from the balcony at
buckingham palace the events come one
day after Megan and Harry attended the
christening of William and Kate's third
child Prince Louis
[Music]